[Music]
50 years ago six women Runners made a
decision that would change the sport
Forever at the first New York City
marathon where women were allowed to
compete instead of running when the race
officially began they sat protesting
inequitable treatment of men and women
in the race five decades later some of
the women are still running but humble
about their impact on the sport
last month in Central Park employees of
the New York Road Runners Club gathered
at the former starting line for the New
York City marathon
to recreate and celebrate an iconic
photograph
[Applause]
a snapshot of six women that changed the
sport of running forever we sat down
with Jane murky Pat Barrett Lynn
Blackstone and Nina Cusick four of the
women from the group that became known
as the six who sat we wanted to make an
impression and we wanted to get things
changed
[Applause]
1972 was the first year women were
allowed to run in the New York City
marathon with just a handful enter but
the amateur athletic Union or AAU which
governed amateur sports required an
altered course or start time for the
women so they were scheduled to begin 10
minutes ahead of the men I mean how
crazy did that seem to you well that's
what didn't make any sense yeah I mean I
was kind of young I didn't understand it
all for six people that didn't make any
sense you know so the six women at the
racist start took a stand by taking a
seat and the New York Times took notice
how was it decided that you were going
to do this protest and sit at the start
of the race I mean it didn't seem fair
to Nina and Pat they were running to
have to adjust their times and the men
that were running were very supportive
and it was really just to show the AAU
that it could be done and it made sense
earlier that year the AAU had lifted its
ban preventing women from competing in
distance races altogether Catherine
Switzer had helped break the gender
barrier at the Boston Marathon I was
amazed in talking to Catherine Switzer
when she told me that a doctor had said
her uterus was going to fall out if she
ran
did any of you
I heard that you heard that one too I've
heard coaches say that yeah
despite how popular running is now it
wasn't always that way women Runners
were subject to harassment in the old
days sometimes people throw things at
you I mean really oh constantly making
or make a terrible I mean it was at the
time of women's Liberation but men were
and young boys they were constantly
making fun of women running if you ran
on the street or or a wow look at those
legs like cat calls yeah and men were
criticized too the marathon was just
starting to
if you weren't coming to what what it is
today I mean it was you know a lot of
men um they even got uh had got hassled
trying to run marathons
[Applause]
after
26.2 miles Nina Cusick won the 1972 New
York City marathon for the women its
first Women's Champion she spoke with
CBS News after how did you feel coming
around that last line
I really felt very good until the last
half of my my legs got a little tight
what do you think about what keeps you
going in that last half mile when you
feel like that
well all kinds of things keep you going
you always wonder who might be coming up
behind you you also have a time in mind
that you're you know trying to finish in
and there's always that negative fear
that you're maybe forced to quit shortly
after the race the AAU dropped it's
separate but equal starting requirement
the six who sat helping change the
course of running insisting on equity in
opportunity
[Applause]
this year nearly 24
000 women are registered to run in the
New York City marathon I hope
development is absolutely amazing never
think of it you know because I or we had
something to do it just the the
development the Evolution for example we
were just talking uh a while ago that
about scholarships and things that are
now available to women yeah it's just
wonderful it's empowering it's it has
helped Empower a lot of it right
you know it's so interesting some of
those women help fight to get the
marathon in the Olympics it has changed
so drastically I thought it was great
too Nina and Pat who finished that race
one and two they talked about the fact
that they had 10 minutes added on to
their time because remember they were
supposed to start right 10 minutes
earlier but they were sitting for those
first 10 minutes in protest but you know
it's moments like this that we have to
remember this is where we came from and
50 years ago wasn't that long ago so
kudos to them and kudos to the New York
Road Runners you know for being there
for these women all along and good luck
to all those men and women